jumanji welcome to the jungle was
directed by Jake Kasdan and stars Dwayne
Johnson Karen Jillian Kevin Hart and
Jack Black and is not quite a reboot
sort of a sequel of the original Jumanji
which came out in the 90s starring the
late Robin Williams rest in peace and
we're in the original film it was a
board game that kids played that brought
the elements of that board game into the
real world like animal stampedes in this
film it's for kids who are stuck in
detention who find an old video game
console and they want to pass the time
so they choose the characters they want
to play and they get sucked into the
world of Jumanji and these kids are now
being portrayed by their avatars and so
as a result you get one of the best
things about this film the fact that the
majority of these actors get to play
against type Jack Black is an Instagram
loving really popular girl at school who
no longer has her phone and is stuck in
an overweight middle-aged man's body in
the middle of the jungle and so Jack
Black has a lot of fun with that Dwayne
Johnson looks like Dwayne Johnson but in
real life he's a kid named Spencer who's
afraid of just about everything
including squirrels and so the rock gets
to have a lot of fun with that and
that's the best part of this film to see
these actors play against type at least
those two Dwayne Johnson and Jack Black
are my favorite parts of this film
Karen Jillian is also really good but
she doesn't play so much against type
and Kevin Hart definitely doesn't
I think Kevin Hart's a brilliant
comedian he can fill a football stadium
with people and you have to respect that
but he basically is playing himself in
the film which was a disappointment
considering that everyone else is having
a lot more fun with their roles and
tweaking their image and making fun of
their image so to speak where Kevin Hart
is once again making a lot of jokes
about his height and the fact that the
rock is a lot bigger than him which is
something we saw a lot in Central
Intelligence and so that was
disappointing because all of the other
actors are having so much fun with these
roles and Hart is basically doing his
schtick surprisingly where I also liked
is how the film has fun with the way a
video game would play out the four
characters meet non-player characters
somebody that's supposed to take them
someplace and they just say the same
stuff over and over again if you ask
them a unique question they just repeat
what they just said because that's what
the videogame wants this character to do
so we have people who just take them
places and then they're like bye and
they walk off and they disappear and you
never see them again because they're a
non-player character and so this film
can have a lot of fun with the way a
videogame is structured it also leads me
to a few of my plot holes which I'll get
into later Bobby Cannavale II plays the
main villain of Jumanji he wants this
glowing green rock and it's explained in
a cutscene it like forces the main
characters to see a cutscene that you
would experience in a video game and you
learn exposition and the plot and it's
kind of funny how it plays with that but
it's also a very lazy way to make your
movie because you have the opportunity
to do that in a place for a joke but at
the same time it's just this big
exposition filled backstory and you just
don't really care about the villain
that's at least my experience with this
movie he just kind of appeared every
once in a while and was very he was just
like this weird creepy guy who had
control over the insects of the jungle
or whatever like he lets them crawl over
his body it was kind of silly there are
plenty of action sequences with a lot of
really great stunt work people flying
all over the place and you could tell
that those are real people doing a lot
of the stunts which I was impressed by
but there is also an over-reliance on
CGI there's a lot of sequences that feel
very heavy on it and I'm fine with CG as
long as it's implemented into the film
well and there were a lot of animals
that were just very noticeable and it
just stood out it was kind of an eyesore
now I mentioned that there were some
potholes most people are just gonna have
fun with their family and watch this
movie and eat popcorn but I couldn't
help but notice some things this is a
film that presents itself as a video
game this world it's a video game they
get sucked into it and it unfolds in
front of them like a video game they
have strengths abilities weaknesses they
can touch a part of their body and then
see their strengths and their weaknesses
everything that you would experience in
a video game the film has fun playing
with those things but they also cut back
to Bobby Cannavale II with his villains
when the lead characters aren't there
suggesting that this world somehow
operates fully functionally not just as
a video game but as an actual universe I
would have liked to have seen them
address that
in the film because as you know a
videogame renders as you experience
things when you're fighting a boss
battle the other boss of the game isn't
like on the other side of the planet
just having a soda like you who render
things as you encounter them and so it
would have been kind of cool like if the
characters climbed a mountain and looked
really far off and we're like wow the
world isn't even I don't even see the
world over there and then as they walk
closer it like renders into view that
would have been a really cool thing but
the film never really addresses why
we're also experiencing things outside
of the cutscenes that the heroes see in
their heads why this world also exists
somewhere else when the main avatars
aren't playing with it another one is
that one of their first objectives is to
find this missing piece no spoilers but
once they find this missing piece you
realize that it was sort of this
coincidence like this thing that just
happened that wouldn't have normally
happened and yet somehow the game
recoded itself for the heroes to have to
include that as an objective which
doesn't quite make sense like a game is
a game unless it can recreate and reform
and it's different than a normal video
game and you can fill in these plot
holes with your own thoughts about why
something might make sense the problem
is is that the film never addresses
these things like if they had a scene
where Spencer who is a very smart
computer savvy character started
realizing that this game is rendering
other things that they're not
experiencing or that it can change its
objectives based off of whatever the
game is experiencing that would have
been really cool and I think it could
have given the film I don't know a few
more layers
now all those plot holes can have
explanations and you can fill in the
gaps and you can say you know what this
is just a fun movie go have a good time
watching it and I'll be honest I did I
had a fun time watching Jumanji but
those are some of the things that bug me
as I watched it because my overactive
brain couldn't stop thinking but in the
end this is a movie where really famous
people get to play against type Jack
black and the rock really stand out Jake
as dan does a pretty good job directing
a lot of fun action sequences the score
is also pretty exciting I had a good
time watching this movie and I think
young kids and families are also gonna
have fun with it but if you start
thinking too much about it it kind of
starts to fall apart a little bit but
it's still a perfectly enjoyable movie
I'm gonna give Jumanji welcome to the
jungle of B - guys thank you so much as
always for watching and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]